♪ ♪
>> Greg: RESIDENT
DUMPSTER FIRE AT THE BORDER AS
JOE GETS READY TO OPEN UP THE
FLOODGATES ENDING TITLE 42.
THAT'S THE HIGHEST MONTHLY TOTAL
IN MORE THAN 22 YEARS BORDER
OFFICIALS ARE WARNING THAT
NUMBER WILL EXPLODE IN MAY WITH
JOE BIDEN OFFICIALLY PULLING THE
PLUG ON THE TRUMP POLICY, THAT
COMES AS OFFICIALS REPORT TO
FOX NEWS THAT NEARLY TWO DOZEN
KNOWN OR SUSPECTED TERRORISTS
WERE CAUGHT TRYING TO CROSS
ILLEGALLY INTO THE COUNTRY LAST
YEAR AT THE HOUSE DOWNPLAYING
THAT REPORT EARLIER.
>> 2,000 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAT
DAY GOT AWAY LAST MONTH I SAY
MIGHT YOU COULD SAY WITH
CERTAINTY NONE OF THEM ARE ON A
TERROR WATCH LIST?
>> OF SUSPECTED TERRORIST
ATTEMPT ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER THEY'RE VERY UNCOMMON.
THESE 23 PEOPLE TO STOP THEM.
>> Greg: IT'S OUR VERY OWN
PETER.
I THINK HE ALSO ASKED JEN
WHETHER OR NOT THE PRESIDENT
WILL BE APOLOGIZING TO THE
BORDER AGENT HE HAD SMEARED BY
BASICALLY ACCUSING THEM OF
MIGRANTS AND CALLING THEM RACIST
AND WHATNOT.
IT WILL THAT IN VIEW FOR A REPLY
OR RESPOND RESPONSE OR JUST YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT THE
MOUNTAIN BORDER PATROL OFFICERS
PRESIDENT ACCUSED OF WHIPPING
MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN NOTIFIED AND
WILL NOT FACE CRIMINAL CHARGES.
SO ONE IS THE PRESENT GOING TO
APOLOGIZE TO THEM.
>> THERE IS A PROCESSED AND
INVESTIGATION OF HOMELAND
SECURITY I DON'T HAVE ANY
UPDATES ON THAT.
>> Greg: DANA, I SMELL A RAT.
>> Dana: IF YOU GO BACK INTO
THAT DAY OF SEPTEMBER OF LAST
YEAR AND YOU WATCH THE VIDEO AND
SEE WHAT HAPPENED THAT AFTERNOON
WITHIN MOMENTS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ARE FAMILIAR WITH HORSES AND THE
WORK THAT THEY ARE DOING NO, NO
SLEEVES THE REINS IN ORDER TO
MANEUVER THE HORSE.
YOU SEE THE VIDEO RIGHT THERE.
THAT AFTERNOON COULD'VE DONE
THAT FOR NEXT LIKE 4-5 DAYS.
THEY KEPT SAYING IT MORE AND
MORE.
THE MEDIA ABSOLUTELY PILED ON
AND THE PRESIDENT SAID BELIEVE
ME THEY'RE GONNA FACE THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
SO THEN THEY HAVE THAT IS
INVESTIGATION THEY PUT THESE
GUYS WERE OUT AND ABOUT DOING A
JOB, WHAT WE HAVE A MIGRANT
CRISIS.
SO A GREAT BOOK FOR MILLENNIALS
OUT THERE.
YES AND WHAT IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO HERE?
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS TO
APOLOGIZE.
AND TO EXPRESS.
IF THEY WERE TO DO THAT AND BE
WILLING TO DO THAT THIS STORY
WOULD GO AWAY.
EVERY DAY THAT THE NOT WILLING
TO DO THIS PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT IT JUST
BECAUSE THE PARTICULAR INCIDENT
IS BECAUSE AS A METAPHOR FOR ALL
THE OTHER THINGS.
CONSISTENTLY ACROSS ALL THE
THINGS WHEN THE THINGS.
IN THOSE NUMBERS ARE VERY LOW.
WHETHER OR NOT AND APOLOGIZE.
COVERED FIVE SECONDS.
THE WOOD APOLOGIZE THEY FIGURED
OVER WITH.
>> Greg: FROM YOUR LEGAL
EXPERTISE IS THERE A LEGAL
REASON WHY THEY WANT TO
APOLOGIZE?
YOU THINK MAYBE BECAUSE THAT
WOULD OPEN THEM UP?
>> Jeanine: THEY ARE ARROGANT
THEY DON'T THINK THAT THEY HAVE
TO APOLOGIZE.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO
THIS COUNTRY.
IF 220,000 COME TO THE BORDER IN
MARCH LOOKING TO GET RID OF
TITLE 42 WHICH ALLOWS THE U.S.
TO TURN AWAY THOSE PEOPLE THAT
WE THINK MIGHT BE A PROBLEM
GIVEN A HEALTH PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE HAD IN THIS COUNTRY.
NOW WHAT THEY WANT TO JUST SAY
IS IT DOESN'T MATTER IT DOESN'T
MATTER WERE JUST GONNA CHANGE
THE COUNTRY WE DON'T CARE WHAT
YOU THINK WHETHER OR NOT YOU
THINK THAT WE THINK ARE RACIST
OR THEY'RE NOT YOU THINK THAT
WAS TO PUT CRIMINALS IN JAIL, OR
WHETHER OR NOT THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE BORDER SECURITY AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY ONE THING ABOUT
THAT.
I'M TIRED OF HEARING THAT THE
BORDER IS BROKEN.
IT'S NOT BROKEN IMMIGRATION LAWS
ARE NOT BROKEN.
PEOPLE JUST DON'T FOLLOW THEM.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING THAT THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
REFUSED TO HEAR THESE ARGUMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA THEREFORE THE TAX
THOSE ARE BROKEN OR NOT BROKEN
THERE ARE JUST THE WAY THEY ARE.
AND SO THEY SAY I'M SORRY?
I DON'T KNOW THAT I'M GOING TO.
BUT CAN THEY SUE IS THE REAL
QUESTION?
CAN THOSE GUYS IS REFERRED TO AS
RACIST SPARROWS OR SO-CALLED
WITS WHICH ARE NOTHING MORE THAN
RAINS YEAH THEY COULD SUE THE
LOSER JOBS, BUT THEY CAN SUE
WITH A WIN?
PROBABLY NOT.
MAYBE THE COLLECTOR NEWSPAPER
AND SAID THAT THE NEWSPAPER WILL
SAY WE WERE RELYING ON THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> Greg: YOU WERE NODDING
ALONG APPARENTLY AGREED WITH
EVANS AND JUDGE SAID?
>> EVERY SINGLE WORD.
OUSTING ABOUT HOW BIG THIS
COUNTRY IS AND THAT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
EXPERIENCE 280 MILLION,
300 MILLION WHATEVER IT IS.
CAN WE TALK ABOUT THAT STORY IN
SEPTEMBER I HAD TO ADMIT THAT I
DO NOT WRITE HORSES OFTEN.
I'M NOT THROWN RAINS AROUND AND
HAVEN'T VISITED THE BORDER.
PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE A LITTLE
MORE EMPATHY JUST KINDNESS
TOWARDS EACH OTHER FOR THEIR
EXPERIENCES AFTER THAT WE WOULD
END UP IN A LOT BETTER PLACE.
WE FUNDAMENTALLY HAVE SIMILAR
FEELINGS ABOUT IMMIGRANTS BUT
THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE IN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM WANT TO COME
HERE WANT TO WORK AND PAY TAXES
IF WE GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
AND WE SEE THAT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
THEY WANT A LEGAL PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP AND PEOPLE ARE FINE
WITH IT.
I WAS LISTENING TO MARK KELLY
AND HE SAID I WANT TITLE 42 GONE
UNTIL THERE ARE SOLUTIONS.
IT FEELS LIKE THERE MIGHT BE A
MOMENT BEFORE WE GET THE 2,024
WHICH CAN BE TERRIBLE LIKE EVERY
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IS WE
COULD COME UP WITH A FEW
SOLUTIONS NOW THAT EVERYONE IS
AMENDED THAT SO MANY PEOPLE COME
ACROSS A BORDER IS TOO MANY.
I FEEL THEY CAN BE PROGRESS.
>> MISSION ACCOMPLISHED THEY'RE
ABLE TO GET THE HOUSE HOPING
STORY AND OSUNA COVER THE FACT
THAT WAS ACCOMPLISHED BORDER
PATROLS REALLY BAD.
I KEEP S AND THE QUESTION.
WHY DO PEOPLE WANT TO SELL DRUGS
INTO COMING TO AMERICA YET YET
TO GET A VISA AND TO THE SYSTEM
GET AN TITUS GO TO MEXICO FROM
ACROSS THE SOUTHERN BORDER, NOT
OF THIS HELPS AMERICA UNDERSTAND
THE STRATEGY BEHIND WHAT
JOE BIDEN IS DOING BECAUSE IT IS
AN UP AMERICA.
>> Jeanine: WHAT IS
JOE BIDEN'S ANGLE?
WHEN DOES IT EVER END?
WHY IS HE DOING IT?
HOW MAY PEOPLE OUT THERE
DESERVES TO BE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
EVERYONE FROM THE SOUTHERN
HEMISPHERE.
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
>> THIS PEOPLE COME OVER WHO
WOULD DO JOBS THAT AMERICANS
WON'T DO.
>> Dana: BY NOT SECURING THE
BORDER IT MAKES LEGAL
IMMIGRATION THAT MUCH HARDER A
LOT OF FRUSTRATION FOR THOSE OF
US HERE AND AS MANY OF US THE
SCENE OF A CERTAIN AT THIS TABLE
THAT WE WANT MORE IMMIGRANTS TO
COME WANT THE PROCESS.
>> Greg: THAT'S ALL, EXACT